la guerra nuclear y ha entrado en el
cuarto mes con una realidad muy
diferente a la que empezó entonces aquel
24 de febrero cuando el presidente
vladimir putin anunció el inicio de esa
operación especial que terminaría siendo
por lo que era una invasión y una guerra
se creyó que esta operación empezaría
por el donbass por esa zona de las
provincias de luhansk y de dones no fue
así realmente esa gran ofensiva comenzó
por el norte del país camino a donde
estamos a la capital kiev con una gran
caravana de tanques y con grandes
ataques a esta ciudad donde las personas
no solamente evacuaron por miles y por
millones sino que también vivían en esos
refugios e incluso en el metro de la
ciudad después de una contraofensiva de
las fuerzas ucranianas las tropas rusas
se retiraron por orden del presidente
vladimir putin y comenzaron semanas
después esto que se llamó la segunda
fase ahora si las tropas fueron a la
zona del donbass donde se libra
actualmente una de las grandes batallas
especialmente en perdón es la segunda
ciudad de la provincia de luján que
actualmente está asediada atacada de
bombardeada constantemente por las
tropas rusas hoy logró entrar casi
milagrosamente una misión humanitaria
que logró sacar a algunas personas que
querían evacuar pero los llamados de
atención sobre lo que pueda pasar sobre
en esta ciudad son bastante grandes se
cree que podría convertirse en una nueva
mariupol como también ha llamado la
atención al presidente ucraniano pro
2000 selenski